helpsters our goal is to get lizzy's
lizard back home now who's got an idea
mr prince thank you uh lizard lizzy said
karen doesn't like the cold so maybe
there are places she is more likely to
be i
see so if we find out what that is then
we can figure out which room karen might
be in oh
we have to find her we will find her mr
prim we will find her but first we have
to do job one learn what kind of places
karen likes oh uh scatter what you got
oh me yeah you scatter oh well once we
know where to look we find karen yeah we
do and that's job two fine karen
then once we find karen we can put her
back inside of her home oh we call her
home a habitat i learned that from billy
bug right about that job three return
karen to her habitat all right helpsters
we have our plan
we've got the plan got the plan we've
figured it out we've got the plan what
happens when we've got the plan we do
have a chat just cause we can't
how do we find out what kind of places
karen likes i have an idea
[Music]
hello i knowing monster
ah
welcome back to wisdom mountain what are
the answers that you seek
what kind of places does caring the
leather like to live in warm places with
trees
learn what kind of places karen likes
check one job done
two more to go
you do know all things i know
karen likes warm places with trees oh
we can use that to make a rule if a room
is warm and it has trees then karen will
like it what about the snowy forest room
yeah but it's not warm yeah that's the
snow oh it needs to be both ah yes then
let's keep looking the jungle room is
warm
and it has trees
the room is both poor manda's trees then
the lizard likes it yeah jungle room
ahoy all right
[Music]
there she is
find karen check
two jobs done one more to go
quick let's get her back in our habitat
karen ran away wow we get her back well
i always show up for food
but how do we find out what foods karen
likes to eat i have an idea
karen eats insects or leafy green
vegetables
karen likes insects or leafy green
vegetables okay
i don't have any insects do you have any
insects i don't have any what are we
supposed to do if we don't have any
insects for goodness sakes well now hold
on mr prim now hart said that karen eats
insects or leafy green vegetables
yeah yeah or no we don't have any
insects but if we find a leafy green
vegetable we might still have a chance
exactly yes mr prim shall we go search
the kitchen we shall mr scatter cody and
i shall stay here and make sure karen
does not leave yeah
now remember the rule if it is green and
a vegetable and leafy then it is the
food karen likes hmm got it let's see
what i got
oh mr prince
how about this is my favorite vegetable
collard greens
it's green and a vegetable and leafy
karen will like it we did it
let's take it to her yes let's
oh is it this way
there's a door there's not that way
[Music]
[Music]
welcome home little one return karen do
her habitat check all the jobs are done
[Music]